bonsoir à tous dans l'actualité ce soir
la france traversée par de violents
orages gros dégâts dans le doubs des
centaines de voitures sont abîmés des
écoles sont fermées lusine peugeot est à
l'arrêt pour plusieurs jours l'alerté
maintenue ce soir dans huit départements
la polémique sur la mission et le
salaire de christine boutin le
gouvernement change de ton il lui
demande de renoncer au cumul de sa
rémunération de 9500 euros et de sa
retraite de député at elle pris une
décision christine boutin nous répondra
elle est notre invité bonsoir et à tout
à l'heure
la percée de l'extrême droite aux pays
bas le parti anti islam de geert fielder
devient la troisième formation du pays
les libéraux les travaillistes vont
devoir former une coalition
profession psychothérapeute le métier
sera désormais encadré après onze ans de
débats passionnés le décret a été publié
il impose une formation et l'inscription
a enregistr nationale pour éviter les
abus
c'est le dossier de cette édition et
puis une page spéciale mondial l'équipe
de france est arrivée au cap dernière
image dernières déclarations à 24 heures
du premier match qui va jouer
comment sont perçus les critiques les
doutes et quelle ambiance sur place
réponse tout à l'heure bienvenue dans ce
journal est d'abord comme chaque jeudi
un rappel il y a maintenant 163 jours
cinq mois et demi donc que nos deux
confrères et collègues de france 3
stéphane taponier et hervé ghesquière
ont été enlevés en afghanistan
nous avons une pensée pour eux et pour
leurs proches
premier titre donc ces orages très
violents qui ont frappé la france et
notamment l'est du pays
dans le doubs les habitants parlent d'un
phénomène exceptionnel la grêle a
perforé les toits les voitures et les
usines amaury guibert avec notre bureau
à strasbourg même derrière une fenêtre
le bruit est assourdissant
partout dans montbéliard des vidéastes
amateurs capture ces instants cela
ressemble un mitraillage en règle
et voici l'un des projectiles
cela va durer plus de quinze minutes il
est à peine 19 heures mais déjà la nuit
semble tomber sur la ville ce matin les
habitants ont réalisé l'ampleur des
dégâts avec les toitures les pare-brise
de voitures sont les principales
victimes
moi j'ai ma voiture la vitre arrière
allait complètement explosé les deux
phares pareil des chocs de comme ça que
d'un bond de quelques uns étaient les
grêlons ce boulanger a conservés comme
des reliques les traces de la bataille
des balles de tennis comme des balles de
tennis
il y avait bien un quart d'heure vingt
minutes qu'ils étaient deux en fait
parmi les sites touchés les usines
peugeot où les verrières de certains
ateliers ont été détruites des chaînes
de montage sont à l'arrêt et ce au moins
jusqu'à lundi
il ya eu beaucoup de dégâts dans la
région les pompiers ont effectué plus de
300 interventions
ce matin dès l'ouverture
certains sinistrés se sont précipités
chez leur assureur
tous espèrent le classement en
catastrophe naturelle le maire et le
préfet vont plaider cette cause auprès
de l'état ont rayé soyez prudent laurent
romejko nous dira tout à l'heure que
l'alerté maintenue dans huit
départements ce soir encore dans le var
et les alpes-maritimes les plages et les
chemins côtiers sont fermés on redoute
des vagues et une élévation du niveau de
la mer chacun a encore en tête les
déferlantes du mois de mai dernier
et puis image d' espagne en galice et
dans les asturies des pluies diluviennes
ont fait sortir les rivières de leurs
cours plusieurs zones sont inondées
comme ici dans le village de barreiro
sous des torrents d'eau ont emporté des
voitures et provoqué des glissements de
terrain à l'étranger encore la poussée
populiste je vous le disais en europe
après la suisse après la hongrie 7 aux
pays-bas que l'extrême droite fait une
perçée les élections législatives
avaient lieu hier le parti anti-islam
devient la troisième formation du pays
claude son père
ses partisans laissent éclater leur joie
hier soir à la surprise générale geert
wilders leader de l'extrême droite aux
pays-bas arrivent en troisième position
lors des élections législatives
mes amis l'impossible miami l'impossible
s'est réalisé ce soir
à 46 ans geert wilders dirige un parti
d'extrême droite pvv qui veut interdire
l'immigration en provenance des pays
musulmans
neuf sièges dans la dernière assemblée
il en obtient aujourd'hui 24 le
vainqueur officiel de la soirée c'est
lui mark rutte
il dirige le parti libéral il arrive en
tête avec 31 sièges
c'est une soirée fantastique juste
derrière il est travailliste avec leur
leader job cohen 30 sièges le grand
perdant des élections c'est lui le
premier ministre sortant chrétien
démocrate
à la télévision les spécialistes
politiques ont eu beaucoup de mal à y
voir clair aucun parti n'a de majorité
au parlement et le prochain gouvernement
sera forcément un gouvernement de
coalition
geert wilders arrivé solide troisième
sera au coeur des négociations
en france les suite de la polémique sur
la mission et le salaire de christine
boutin on l'évoqué tiers 9500 euros par
mois plus les avantages pour un rapport
sur la mondialisation
dans la majorité même plusieurs voix se
sont joints aujourd'hui au concert de
protestations mais c'est surtout le
gouvernement qui a changé ton il lui
demande de renoncer au cumul de sa
rémunération et de sa retraite de
députée christine boutin qui est restée
silencieuse depuis ce matin nous
répondra dans un instant d'abord on fait
le point avec thierry curtea nitry boire
depuis deux jours christine boutin tente
d'enrayer la course médiatique
le canard enchaîné révélait hier que la
ministre s'est vu confier une mission
sur les conséquences sociales de la
mondialisation
pour ce rapport elle touche 9500 euros
mensuels qui s'ajoutent aux 6000 euros
de sa retraite de député et aux 2000
euros de fonds mandat de conseiller
général des yvelines 7500 euros de
revenus au total donc pour remplir sa
mission
elle dispose de locaux et de quatre
collaborateurs rémunérés entre 4500 et
6000 euros par mois 22000 euros total
pour eux
trois d'entre eux sont des proches il
milite dans le parti de christine boutin
l'ancienne ministre du logement à la
fibre sociale très développée à quitter
le gouvernement il y a un an
aujourd'hui pour ses ex-collègues
l'addition ne passe pas
j'ai un tempérament auvergnats donc
l'eau verneuil trouve que dans toute
chose il faut de l' équilibre et là je
pense que l'on est au delà de
l'équilibré
eric woerth estime que si la situation
de christine boutin choque l'opinion
il faut alors la clarifier y a rien
d'illégal donc il faut changer les
règles notamment probablement de
regarder plus près tout ce qui est cumul
entre une retraite pension de retraite
et puis une fonction publique rémunérée
il lui demande donc de choisir entre ces
rémunérations
ce matin françois fillon s'est vu
interpellé sur le sujet il ya eu ce
matin recadrage eric woerth il a refusé
de répondre car ce que la gauche se dit
choqué et observe à distance la
polémique à droite installée cette idée
qu'il peut y avoir ou récompense pour
services rendus ou récompense pour
services à rendre
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment détestable
explication ce salaire serait t'il une
contrepartie pour que christine boutin
ne se présente pas à la future élection
présidentielle
l'assemblée nationale bernard accoyer a
appelé christine boutin pour lui
demander de renoncer le temps de sa
mission à ta retraite de député bonsoir
alix bouilhaguet vous êtes en direct au
ministère des affaires sociales le
gouvernement semble découvrir la sphère
qui exactement est à l'origine de cette
mission confiée à christine boutin
bonsoir dhabi david a et puis écouter
d'après nos informations c'est bel et
bien l'elysée qui a accordé une mission
à christine boutin christine boutin
souhaité en avoir une et nicolas sarkozy
a accepté alors concernant les moyens et
notamment la rémunération cette fois-ci
l'elysée renvoie sur matignon
c'est le secrétaire général du
gouvernement sous la tutelle du premier
ministre qui décide d'octroyer ou non
des collaborateurs un bureau et c'est
notamment lui qui fixe le niveau de
rémunération alors dans l'entourage du
chef de l'état on estime que la mission
est une grande contribution pour le g20
et que christine boutin est compétente
et qu'elle a l'expérience
en clair une réponse à tous ceux qui
estiment que cette mission et n'a pour
unique objectif de dissuader christine
boutin
être candidate à la présidentielle de
2012 alix bouilhaguet au ministère des
affaires sociales
merci alix pour soir christine boutin en
soit on l'a entendu le gouvernement vous
demande de choisir entre cette
rémunération pour cette mission et votre
retraite de député avez vous pris une
décision
oui j'ai pris une décision et ce n'est
pas le gouvernement qui me demande je
suis suffisamment grande pour savoir ce
que j'ai à faire
j'ai une mission c'était absolument
superbe qui touche à la vie de chacun
d'entre nous sur la mondialisation la
tension sociale qui existe dans les pays
développés comme les pays en
développement
et puis c'est une vraie mission sur
lequel nous travaillons avec des
contacts de très haut niveau je vais
être je travaille avec monsieur steve
its avec monsieur yunus
je joue beaucoup de gens réfléchissent
des pieux dans les cabinets le seul
problème c'est que je ne sais pas si
vous avez bien remarqué que la crise
elle est là depuis deux ans et qu'en
réalité il faut regarder par rapport au
g20 dont la france va être la présidente
pendant un an
quelles sont les propositions que l'on
peut faire aux autres pays du g20 et il
attend beaucoup
j'ai rencontré des chiliens des
brésiliens des africains qui attendent
beaucoup de la voix de la france à
l'occasion de ce g20 donc cette mission
je vous le dit david pujadas et à vous
tous qui regardent et france 2 eh bien
je la mènerai le problème de la
polémique sur mes revenus
je dois dire comme l'a dit monsieur
woerth tout à l'heure et sont totalement
légaux ma retraite est le résultat de
mes 25 ans à l'assemblée nationale j'ai
donné toute ma vie j'ai cotisé et j'aime
un droit à la retraite
je suis toujours conseil général j'ai
droit à une indemnité comme tout est
alors le salaire qui m'a été octroyés
pour la mission
elle correspond à un haut niveau de
responsabilité et de mon expérience
politique de 25 ans parlementaire deux
ans deux ministres donc l'équivalent
d'un salaire de haut fonctionnaire qui
est à 9500 francs
est-ce que 500 0,10 alors âgée dans que
décidée alors que tout est légal
ce qui pose une question fondamentale
qui est celle de savoir dans un état de
droit où la loi est respectée s'il faut
plier sous le poids de la tourmente
médiatique
mais ce n'est pas ça ce qui m'a fait
décider et ma décision je les prix hier
soir la décision gelée prière au sort
parce que j'ai entendu les français qui
ont de petits salaires
qui aujourd'hui ne peuvent pas
comprendre qu'il y ait ainsi un
responsable politique qui puisse avoir
un montant de rémunération de deux
rentrées d'argent de 18 minutes près de
18000 euros
j'ai donc décidé de mener cette mission
de façon gracieuse en renonçant à 1009
1500 euros ce qui est moins intéressant
que ce que proposait monsieur woerth
dans son émission de ce matin où ils me
disaient d'abandonner la la retraite
pour renoncer à ce salaire aux avantages
qui vont avec aussi les avantages du
collaborateur alors j'écoutais si on
enlève les collaborateurs à ce moment là
disons que c'est très très cette mission
n'a aucun intérêt qu'il faut pas
l'amener parce que moi une mission d'une
importance comme celle ci je ne peux pas
les mener tout seul donc bien sûr mes
collaborateurs je les garde
mais je renonce aux 9500 euros kim était
octroyé de façon légale pour assumer
cette mission c'est une décision qui a
été difficile à prendre
non elle n'a pas été difficile parce que
j'ai été touché par les mois que ceci a
provoqué chez les français mais vous
savez moi je suis en train de créer une
jurisprudence avec cette décision
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui se
trouvent dans cette situation et qui
vont aujourd'hui ou demain être
confrontés au même problème
est ce que vous comprenez tout de même
christine boutin que quand vous avez
entendu tirer à boulet rouge sur le
gouvernement au moment de votre sortie
l'équipe gouvernementale puis un relatif
silence et on s'est aperçu qu'en même
temps que ce changement de ton il y
avait ce changement de statut avec cette
mission alors on se pose forcément la
question de savoir si d'une certaine
manière c'était pas une façon d'acheter
entre guillemets votre soutien c'est
aussi dans la polémique quelque chose
qui m'a profondément blessé
moi qui suis une femme de conviction qui
suis une femme libre qu'on puisse
laisser entendre qu'on pouvait m'acheter
mon silence
vraiment c'est pas c'est inacceptable
pour moi continuerez à critiquer le
gouvernement mais qui m'aiment bien sûr
et je vous le dis très clairement
il est tout à fait possible que je me
présente à l'élection en 2012 à la
présidentielle
je crois que ce pays va mal je crois que
la paix sociale est très fragilisée et
moi c'est toujours la fragilité qui a
mené mon combat politique et je
continuerai le mener et je ferai une
belle mission vous le verrez dès le mois
d'octobre et en janvier j'aurai des
propositions innovantes et j'espère que
la presse sera aussi attentive à mes
propositions qu'elles ont et
tu es sur mes revenus merci christine
boutin d'avoir répondu à nos questions
ce soir l'actualité judiciaire avec
l'ouverture demain d'un procès de la
maltraitance vous vous souvenez
peut-être de la sphère du petit dylan ce
garçon maltraité pendant des années par
ses propres parents dans l'aveyron
enfermé battu brimer jamais scolarisé
le couple risque jusqu'à cinq ans de
prison sur place niel la saga david bres
la maison où vivaient dylan est
désormais vide
la mère vit dans un foyer le père est
sorti de détention provisoire en avril
dernier le petit garçon n'a plus vu ses
parents depuis un an en mars 2009
les policiers de millau découvre la
chambre de dylan huit ans ici avec son
petit frère un dénuement total
un matelas souillé par l'uriné car
chaque soir l'enfant est enfermé dans
cette chambre noire ses parents le
trouve trop turbulents pour l'avocat du
père de dylan
nous ne sommes pas en présence de
tortionnaires mais plutôt face à une
misère sociale et intellectuelle
je crois qu'on ne peut pas croire que ce
couple était complètement conscient de
tout ce qu'il faisait ou de toutes les
conséquences entraînées leur
comportement son comportement à l'égard
de l'enfant
le couple avait décidé de ne pas
scolariser les enfants pas de suivi
médical non plus mais des coûts souvent
aujourd'hui
dylan vit dans une famille d'accueil
séparer de son frein cet enfant va comme
il peut aller suite au fait qu'il a
subis pendant plusieurs années il
retrouve un quotidien normal pour un
enfant de son âge il est scolarisé
scolarisés à 9 ans pour la première fois
de sa vie ses parents risque entre cinq
et sept ans de prison
ils seront jugés demain en bref les
dernières heures du congrès de la cfdt
invité remarquer aujourd'hui bernard
thibault la cfdt qui a donné par
ailleurs son feu vert malgré de vives
tensions un éventuel allongement de la
durée de cotisation pour la retraite
mais avec des conditions qui je cite ne
sont pas réunies aujourd'hui il
sinueux et emmanuel maurel la belgique
s'apprête à vivre des heures décisives
ce sont des élections capitales pour
l'avenir du pays qui sont organisées ce
dimanche les partis séparatistes
flamands sont donnés favoris
voici à quoi ressemble la vie
quotidienne dans les zones mixtes
flamandes et wallonnes de culture de
langue tout est sujet à discorde
reportage françois beaudonnet bertrand
catrice en bien en belgique est connu
pour sa cité médiévale et sa bière
artisanale n'est sa particularité la
plus frappante
la voici une ligne invisible au milieu
de cette route
ici vous êtes sous la frontière
linguistique d'un côté de la rue vous
avez 4 millions de wallons et de l'autre
côté
signons des flamands une frontière sans
barrière ni grillage mais qui depuis
coupe officiellement le royaume en deux
parties comme la caserne du village la
particularité de la caserne c'est
d'avoir quatre portes de garage sur la
wallonie et la cinquième sur la flandre
tpr a fait venir enfants mothern
n'aidera strict
c'est à dire nous devons parler
néerlandais c'est ce que font les
pompiers d'enghien pourtant tous
francophones alors ici plus qu'ailleurs
ils veulent croire que l'incendié entre
flamands et wallons ne fera pas exploser
la belgique
jamais jusque là et je crois que pour
trouvera comme d'habitude mais en vérité
le compromis à la belge ne fonctionne
plus pour preuve l'aéroport
international de bruxelles
il est le théâtre d'une interminable
bataille entre les deux communautés
en jeu la décision des autorités de
faire voler les avions surtout au dessus
des banlieues francophone c'est cette
mystique qui qui est utilisée parce que
ici au bout de ses fils ce sont les
communes où la population est
majoritairement francophone en belgique
les avions ne décollent donc pas
toujours face au vent je connais aucun
autre pays au monde où on va décider où
les avions vont passer ou ne pas passer
pour une raison comme une affaire
politique
et c'est justement sur ce genre de
blocage linguistique que surf les
indépendantistes flamands pour demander
à terme la mort de la belgique des
indépendantistes qui dimanche pourrait
bien remporter ces élections
en bref encore à l'étranger à chaque
jour ces attentats en afghanistan un
kamikaze s'est fait exploser au milieu
de centaines de convives qui
participaient à un mariage dans le sud
du pays il y à 40 morts et 70 blessés au
moins il est 20 heures et 16 minutes
rester avec nous à suivre le deuxième
pays du monde s'ouvre à l'éducation
l'école devient obligatoire en inde pour
300 millions d'enfants nous irons sur
place profession psychothérapeute le
métier sera désormais encadré après onze
ans de débats passionnés le décret a été
publié
et puis une page spéciale mondial
l'équipe de france est arrivée au cap
dernière image dernières déclarations à
la veille du premier match qui va jouer
comment sont perçus les critiques et les
doutes et quelle ambiance sur place
réponse dans un instant d'abord donc un
géant du monde en mouvement le parlement
indien a voté l'enseignement gratuit et
obligatoire pour tous les enfants de 6 à
14 ans et une avancée c'est un défi
aussi dans ce pays d'un milliard et 150
millions d'habitants
reportage pierre monet
j ai dominique marault tél ils n'ont
jamais vu une salle de classe pour ses
enfants le quotidien se partage entre
corvées ménagères et travaux des champs
officiellement le travail des enfants
est interdite en inde mais aujourd'hui
encore ils sont plus de 10 millions
comme buddhadeb huit ans a rapporté
quelques roupies essentiels à leur
famille moi j'aimerais aller à l'école
parce que j'aimerais devenir docteur
dans le meilleur des cas s'ils ne vont
pas à l'école
c'est l'école qui vient à eux dans ce
bidonville de délits ce vieux bus
scolaire a été réaménagé en classe
ambulante
un projet financé entièrement par une
association privée quand il fait
vraiment trop chaud la leçon se
poursuit' dehors à l'ombre des manguiers
sous le regard de leurs parents qui
n'ont reçu aucune éducation
ces petits oubliés du système tente
d'échapper à leur destin
moi j'adore mon école et plus tard je
veux être institutrice mais les
bénévoles se heurtent souvent aux
réticences des adultes il est souvent
les parents qui entend pas les enfants
parce qu'il comprend pas l'utilité
d'apprendre à lire écrire est
voilà les femmes c'est ainsi que se
construit une inde à deux vitesses à
l'autre bout de l'échelle sociale des
écoles privées comme celle ci très cher
et à moitié vide mais bientôt ces
écoliers devront se serrer sur les bancs
les autorités veulent tia soir 25 %
d'enfants défavorisés et faire de
l'éducation pour tous une cause
nationale
si je peut éduquer tous ces enfants
c'est sur mon pays s'en portera mieux
officiellement à la rentrée prochaine
tous les petits indiens auront les mêmes
droits
l'école sera gratuite et obligatoire
pour 300 millions d'enfants de 6 à 14
ans mais selon ce directeur d'école
cela ne suffira pas à delhi ça va encore
90% des enfants vont à l'école et dans
les campagnes près d'un tiers d'entre
eux ne sont pas scolarisés du tout en
attendant les plus courageux
s'organisent pour étudier par leurs
propres moyens même coincé entre
l'aéroport de delhi est une voie ferrée
à la rentrée ils auront peut-être une
place dans une véritable école d'ici là
ce bout de trottoir fera office de salle
de classe
c'est pas facile avec tous ses avions au
dessus de nos têtes
mais si on veut étudier on n'a pas le
choix partout en inde des milliers
d'écoles de la rue comme celle ci voit
le jour car derrière les annonces du
gouvernement le manque de moyens est
telle que plus de 10 millions d'enfants
indien reste encore au bord du chemin
en bref nicolas sarkozy en visite à bord
du porte avions charles de gaulle
aujourd'hui en rade de toulon le
président de la république s'est engagé
à préserver les capacités
opérationnelles de l'armée tout en
indiquant qu'elle devrait participer à
l'effort de redressement des finances
il a confirmé que la décision sur la
construction d'un second porte-avions
serait prise l'an prochain en 2011
images signées alain duban la santé
c'est un très vieux débat qui vient
d'être tranché ces derniers jours le
métier de psychothérapeute sera
désormais encadré le décret a été publié
malgré l'opposition de beaucoup de
professionnels ils imposent une
formation et l'inscription à un registre
national
il s'agit de tenter de donner le maximum
de garanties aux millions de personnes
qui ont recours est de limiter les abus
aussi c'est le dossier de cette édition
il est signé nabila taboury christophe
kenck avec notre bureau à rennes
traumatisé par un violent delphine ne
s'est pas méfié lors des premières
séances
si son psychothérapeute la jeune femme
le consulte sur les conseils d'une amie
les mois passent elle va de plus en plus
mal sa thérapie semble inadapté vous
m'avez diagnostic et obsessionnelle
après il m'avait dit finalement que
j'étais nerveuse et obsessionnelle parce
que je n'arrivais pas à me sortir de
l'histoire que j'avais vécu disait
concernant ma vie privée
mariez vous faites fait un enfant on m'a
dit que j'étais coincé qu'il fallait que
je prenne
est ce que comme les diabétiques prendra
des médicaments toute ma vie donc là je
me suis dit maintenant faut que j'arrête
la thérapie complètement parce que sinon
il va complètement me détruire et
delphine a tout arrêté
aujourd'hui elle est suivie à l'hôpital
par une psychologue et psychothérapeute
il y en a quinze mille en france et
environ 4500 n'ont aucune formation
reconnue jusqu'à présent il leur
suffisait simplement de poser une plaque
pour pouvoir consulter si la plupart des
psychothérapeutes ne pose aucun problème
une petite minorité est composée d'
escroc et c'est sur l'un d'eux qui est
tombé martin il y a dix ans elle a
consulté une psychothérapeute d'abord
pour son fils qui refusait d'aller à
l'école ensuite pour elle après la mort
de son père elle est complètement sous
emprise
la psychothérapeute la convainc de
quitter son travail de déscolariser son
fils elle réussit même à lui faire
croire à de faux souvenirs pour
expliquer son mal être se pourrait très
bien que j'ai vécu un insecte c'est que
je me rappelle pas de cette période là
et
c'est pour ça que j'ai du mal à vivre
celui qui est un malaise c'est rare de
l'entendre dire par une personne en qui
j'avais confiance
comme ça totalement moi ça m'a
complètement déstabilisée et quand on
est ni manipulée dans ce sens là on
n'arrive pas à juger de la situation
on est complètement pris dans un
engrenage jusqu'à présent la profession
de psychotérapeute n'était pas
réglementé un vide juridique auquel
s'est attaqué le président de
l'assemblée pour ouvrir un cabinet il
faudra désormais obtenir un diplôme
universitaire et sur des stages de
formation obligatoire ce sont des hommes
des femmes des têtes de bonne volonté et
souvent dangereux qui s'autoproclament
psychothérapeute c'est un nom rassurant
il y avait besoin
derrière ce titre il ya des garanties
c'est désormais ce qui est juste
pourquoi une telle réglementation a mis
des années à voir le jour simplement
parce que cette profession qui s'est
construite sur une totale liberté des
pratiques est opposé à tout encadrement
et pour beaucoup de professionnels le
diplôme garantie certes une formation
minimale mais ce n'est pas un label de
qualité
ce que nous critiquons dans ce choix
s'est il privilégie la formation par un
diplôme par rapport à la formation qui
exige d'abord d'avoir fait un travail
sur soi puisque les psychologues qui
reçoivent un diplôme de psychologue de
l'université où les médecins et bien
souvent les psychiatres n'ont fait aucun
travail personnel martine elle a failli
sombrer après la manipulation elle a
vécu la dépression puis
l'hospitalisation un engrenage dont elle
se remet peu à peu aujourd'hui
en bref on a appris la mort de la
comédienne ginette garcin ce matin des
suites d'une longue maladie
chanteuse à ses débuts elle avait entamé
une carrière au cinéma et au théâtre
dans les années soixante dix à la
télévision aussi jusqu'à ces derniers
jours avec famille d'accueil sur france
3 qui n'aide garcin avait 82 ans
on en vient à notre page spéciale
football coup d'envoi du mondial demain
faut-il le préciser on va suivre des
supporters français à la découverte du
pays
on verra aussi les images fortes de la
journée mais d'abord on va parler de
l'équipe de france
elle vient d'arriver au cap à 24 heures
de son match contre l'uruguay
julien benedetto mathieu gardel
entre doutes et espoirs l'équipe de
france est arrivée au cap
il y à quelques minutes criblé de
critiques ces derniers temps les bleus
ont sans doute apprécié l'accueil
enthousiaste de cette cinquantaine de
supporteurs demain on va enfin savoir si
ces bleus là sont taillés pour l'exploit
si ça se passe mal c'est pas pour ça que
tout va s'écrouler et qu'on va s'arrêter
et les matches de qualification ce que
j'étais tout à l'heure on a mal débuté
mais on s'en est sorti et c'est ce que
c'est ce que je dis c'est que si ces
même si ça va être difficile au premier
match et ça va être difficile après
aussi on arrivera toujours à s'en sortir
ce matin la bande à ribéry s'est
entraîné une dernière fois à nice n'a
huis clos de rigueur raymond domenech
cultive le mystère jusqu'au bout mais sa
composition des équipes n'a semble-t-il
plus de secret avec la défense attendus
gourcuff et malouda au milieu et un trio
govou anelka ribéry
chargé de faire taire les critiques il y
à quelques minutes la sélection
uruguayenne a découvert le flamboyant
stade greenpoint pour la france cette
pelouse sera demain le théâtre des rêves
où le chant des désillusions et je vous
propose précisément en d'écouté raymond
domenech il donnait une conférence de
presse il y à quelques instants on
écoute le sélectionneur il faut gérer on
est 23 prêts déterminés
je pense pas que le mot qu'on puisse
données sur l'esprit des joueurs ce soit
calmes ils ont envie déterminés ils sont
prêts la limite même un peu agressifs et
impatients
voilà bonsoir magnoti si vous êtes en
direct au capes que l'équipe de france
et son sélectionneur d'ailleurs ont des
échos des doutes et les critiques aussi
qu'il suscite en france
oh que oui
oh que oui vous savez que à l'ère
d'internet et du téléphone portable ils
sont au courant de tous les épluche même
pour certains les journaux à la manière
d'un thierry henry qui n'a quasiment
rien de ce qu'on est sur l'équipe de
france et qui parfois même décroche son
téléphone pour dire sa façon de penser
aux journalistes ou aux patrons de
chaînes qui auraient un petit peu trop
critiquer l'équipe de france et c'est
vrai que même dans leur bulle à nice n'a
leur reviennent les échos des doutes qui
traverse le pays
des doutes qu'ils expriment aussi en
conférence de presse il ne s'avance pas
très sûrs d'eux sur cette rencontre est
tout à leur raymond domenech à l'instant
il est toujours en conférence de presse
en ce moment même juste un étage au
dessous de moi dans ce stade avec
patrice evra disait que les joueurs
étaient agressifs et il a dit quelque
chose à son sujet et c'est très rare il
parle très rarement lui-même mais il a
dit que pour lui il pouvait résister à
la pression jusqu'au 12 juillet c'est à
dire que la finale le 11 juillet le
lendemain de la finale et qui après
cette date ils brûleraient donc il a
montré sa première faille pour montrer
qui est bien la pression était quand
même très forte sur lui
mais après le 12 juillet il ne sera plus
sélectionneur de l'équipe de france donc
il pourra un petit peu brûlé que l'
aventure se poursuivre jusqu'au 12
juillet c'est bien sur ce qu'on souhaite
à l'équipe manuel tissier au cap merci
manuel les supporters français aussi
sont là ils sont arrivés nos envoyés
spéciaux dominique derda et frédéric
rend con suivi l'un d'entre eux avec ses
amis pour dénicher l'emblème national
un coq il s'est aventuré dans les
bidonvilles du cap
voici leurs reportages l'avis de
supporters vous conduit parfois dans de
drôles d'endroits
ce qui nous amène aux boulettes ou est
l'un des ghettos noirs les plus pauvres
des environs du cap l'un des plus
dangereux
j'aime en tomaszewski son fils et leurs
amis viennent y acheter un coq
l'indispensable mascotte sans laquelle
il ne peut y avoir de coupe du monde
réussie pour clément d'antibes ce sera
sa 6e
je crois qu'ils achètent pour faire de
la sorcellerie pour que la france gagne
la coupe du monde 250 30,25 euros pour
un kop qu'il compte bien emmener avec
lui à chacun des matchs derrière eux à
fuir parmi les supporters français
clément d'antibes est une vedette un
passionné qui s'est endettée bien au
delà du raisonnable pour s'offrir le
voyage
en attendant la première rencontre
demain soir face à l'uruguay
ils visitent la région mésylate et ses
compagnons eux aussi de se retrouver
dans l'enceinte du stade de greenpoint
et d'encourager les joueurs de l'équipe
de france qu'il soutiendra jusqu'au bout
contre vents et marées je suis confus
région prendre chambre d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça que j'ai pris tous les billets
pour en ce jour
le 11 juillet le jour de la finale que
clément imagine contre l'espagne car la
france dit il a une revanche à prendre
ce soir là une fois la victoire acquise
il rendra la liberté à balthazar le coq
de gourou les to et rentrera le coeur
léger jusqu'à anti les bleus lui doivent
bien ça ça fait 28 ans qu'à travers le
monde ils portent leur couleur et
croient en leur bonne étoile
voilà pour ceux qui ne suivent pas
forcément les choses de près florent
gautreau nous a rejoint bonsoir florent
au sort david qui sont les favoris de ce
mondial l'espagne au premier rang de ses
favoris évidemment invaincue depuis
douze matches championne d'europe en
titre est la larme fatale fernando
torres il a 26 ans et a déjà marqué 24
buts avec la sélection espagnole
deuxième favori le brésil le brésil qui
a participé à toutes les phases finales
de coupe du monde qui a déjà cinq
trophées à son actif
troisième équipe évidemment l'argentine
du duo médiatique mais si maradona messi
sans doute le meilleur joueur du monde
maradona qui a déjà gagné cette coupe du
monde en tant que joueur qui va essayer
de le faire en tant que sélectionneur
et puis l'angleterre qui attend le titre
mondial depuis 1966 et derrière quels
sont les nations qui sont en embuscade
il ya beaucoup de nations très proches
en fait les pays bas avec leurs stars
arjan robben mais également l'allemagne
toujours présente dans les grands rendez
vous c'est un poncif mais c'est vrai
l'italie championne du monde en titre on
est bien placé pour le savoir mais qui
est un peu vieillissante et le portugal
de cristiano ronaldo dont je remarque
que vous n'avez pas parlé de la france
je sors mon joker david parce que c'est
vrai que c'est compliqué les bookmakers
ce matin situe la cote de la france à 15
contre 1 une cote d'outsider mais c'est
vrai que les français ont souvent réussi
dans les tournois alors qu'ils n'étaient
pas favoris on se raccroche à ses
statistiques car il ya beaucoup de
doutes autour des bleus et pour terminer
s'il y avait une équipe qui pouvait
créer la surprise
peut-être l'uruguay et que vous allez
découvrir demain à contre la france
uruguay un formidable duo d'attaqué
forlan suarez ce sera peut-être l'une
des surprises de cette coupe du monde
merci florent et à ce propos voici le
résultat de la question de la semaine
l'équipe de france passe rappelle le
premier tour de la coupe du monde et
bien l'optimisme n'est pas vraiment de
mise non 58% oui 22 pour cent ne se
prononcent pas 20% vous avez été plus de
19 il a voté merci à tous et avant de
refermer ce journal un détour par le
plateau d'à vous de juger
bonsoir arlette chabot on va aussi
parler football
chez vous ce soir mais pas seulement oui
mais on parlera aussi positif mairie
quelqu'un qui aime bien marquer des buts
ça t'a jean françois copé et c'est vrai
que cette année il a plutôt
effectivement marqué des points au sein
de la majorité face au gouvernement et
au président de la république il sera
face aussi à cécile duflot qui également
est en progrès dans l'équipe politique
france en général
et puis bien sûr à la veille de la coupe
du monde de football de l'ouverture dont
on vient de parler mais nous aussi nous
parlerons justement du poids du sport du
football dans la vie des états de
l'équipe de france de raymond domenech
de l'argent enfin tout ce qui va avec
bien entendu les questions liées à la
coupe du monde et aux équipes avec
rosine baciocchi ministre de la santé et
des sports avec bernard tapie aurélie
filippetti et pape diouf
et voilà donc beaucoup de football ce
soir et beaucoup de débats comme
d'habitude à vous de juger
on vous retrouve dans quelques instants
arlette fin de cette édition je vous en
rappelle l'un des principaux titres la
polémique sur la mission et le salaire
de christine boutin
il y à quelques minutes en direct sur ce
plateau l'ancien ministre nous annoncer
qu'elle renonce à son salaire de 9500
euros par mois pour cette mission comme
le gouvernement le lui demandait il lui
demandait en tout cas de faire un choix
d'arbitrer entre cette rémunération et
sa retraite de députée christine boutin
qui estime que cette décision devra
faire jurisprudence
merci à vous tous ou tu te la météo
laurent romejko qui ne va pas vraiment
nous redonner le moral 20h35 à vous de
juger dont 23h10 le grand concert de la
coupe du monde à johannesburg avec sur
scène les black eyed peas alicia keys et
bien d'autres demain 13h à lise lui
c'est 20 heures et le week-end laurent
delahousse très bonne soirée
l'info en continu
c'est aussi sur france 2 point fr